in this morning's saturday session we
take you down under with a master of
musical theater and comedy
tim minchin grew up in western australia
and developed a worldwide following
now he's in sydney where he's released a
remarkable new album
he'll perform in a moment but first his
interview with our very own
anthony mason appreciate the risk you
took the bookers who agreed to book a
chap who tends to talk about the kind of
things that get the bbc tim mentioned
in hot water made his name performing
musical satire
you've been put kind of in the comedy
category but i know you don't really
think of yourself as a comedian
it was a hell of a shock to me that i
made my name doing comedy i certainly
didn't grow up going one day i'm gonna
grab a microphone and tell jokes your
love for me is not debatable
in australia where he was raised mention
started out performing in clubs
delectable inflatable you
before long he was playing arenas
[Music]
around the world like royal albert hall
in london it's sort of almost immodest
my joy of mucking around with language
and trying to unpack
the sort of ideas that don't usually get
unpacked in songs
then out of the blue the royal
shakespeare company approached him about
writing a musical
based on roald dahl's book matilda it
seemed unbelievable that i was being
asked to do this project because it felt
so right
and yet i walked out going i shouldn't
do that i'm
i'm taking off i'm going to be a star
i'm going to be a comedian
i think my agent in the uk said oh don't
be an idiot it's the world shakespeare
company just do it
it's the best thing i've ever done
matilda the musical opened in london in
2011
on broadway two years later and it's
still running
around the globe you get buckets of
awards all over the world
yeah i actually have a set of buckets
that i keep them in
[Laughter]
on the heels of matilda's success
mention had plans for an
animated musical and moved to los
angeles
loved the place loved the people found
the sort of
unashamed ruthlessness that the business
didn't didn't suit me hugely
the musical didn't happen i wrote this
song on an
airport piano but a new album did
disturbing your journey from security i
wrote this record in the kind of
slight funk that i experienced after
after
[Music]
a part together is mention's first
studio album
some people are calling this a serious
album it just seems like sort of a silly
word
very very serious take me seriously
why won't you believe me i have feelings
tim mentioned has always been serious
about making his own kind of music none
of these songs are getting played on
radio i mean it's
absolutely amazing that you guys are
going to let me play some of them
because
they're long and they don't follow
normal form and they're a little bit
different but i i'm very lucky in that
i've i sort of
don't care